we put our lives
in your hands trusting you
with all our tomorrows
lord you bless us with your peace
even in the midst of life's storms
uphold our senators
give them hours that sustain
rather than stress permit
the rhythm of your truth
to free them from the bondage
that debilitates
may they find strength in you
as they give you their restlessness
and doubts we pray
in your wonderful name
please join me in reciting the pledge of
allegiance to the flag
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united
and to the states for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
the clerk will read a communication to
the senate washington dc december 31
2020 to the senate under the provisions
of rule one paragraph three of the
standing rules of the senate
i hereby appoint the honorable deb
fischer a senator from the state of
nebraska to perform the duties of the
chair
signed chuck grassley president
pre-temporary
madame the majority leader i moved to
proceed to calendar number
480s 3985
the clerk will report calendar number
480s 3985 a bill to improve and reform
policing practices
accountability and transparency under
the previous order the leadership time
is reserved
mr president the majority leader
yesterday the senate was finally able to
proceed to this year's
national defense authorization act a few
of our democratic colleagues have pulled
out
all the stops to hold back this crucial
bill
but last night a big bipartisan majority
of 80
senators voted to proceed
there should be nothing controversial
about giving our brave men and women in
uniform
the tools and training they need to stay
safe there should be nothing
controversial about continuing the work
of rebuilding and modernizing our
capabilities
it should be a non-partisan proposition
that america
should keep pace with russia and china
rather than slip behind we've enacted an
annual ndia for 59 straight years
and counting in the next few days the
easy way or the hard way we're
going to do our job once again
this body will fulfill our
responsibility to the men and women who
protect
our country so the senate will be here
until we finish this bipartisan
legislation now for several days we've
heard some senators say congress must
send more cash
to higher earning households who haven't
seen any income disruption
during covet 19. our colleagues who
purport to be the champions of
vulnerable americans now say that what
struggling people really need
is for congress to stop focusing on
targeted relief for them specifically
and to instead send thousands of dollars
to people
who don't need the help experts from
across the political spectrum agree that
our colleague from vermont is
dead wrong on this socialism for rich
people is a terrible way to help the
american families that are actually
struggling
so let me say that again borrowing from
our grandkids to do socialism for rich
people is a terrible way to get help
to families who actually need it
washington democrats took president
trump's suggestion and skewered it
so the checks would benefit even more
even more
high-ending households imagine a family
of five where the parents earn 250
000 per year and have not seen any
income loss this past
year speaker pelosi and senator sanders
want to send them five thousand dollars
from uncle sam
they make a quarter of a million dollars
nobody's out of work
but our so-called progressive friends
say the household needs quote
survival checks in fact they believe a
family of five should have to earn
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
before the spigot
of government money would stop entirely
socialism for rich people that's what
speaker pelosi and senator sanders
have sketched out a terrible way to help
those
who need it and experts across the
political spectrum agree
the liberal editors the washington post
had blasted so-called progressives
demanding a non-targeted giveaway that
would
huge amounts to perfectly comfortable
families
larry summers who ran the treasury
department for president clinton
and the national economic council for
president obama
says there is quote no good economic
argument end quote for more non-targeted
checks
with no linkage to need the liberal new
york times reported this morning that a
majority of the households that get
non-targeted checks do not end up
spending them on urgent needs
but rather just add to their savings
quote
we know where the pockets of need are
end quote said one economist
and quote putting money there would be a
much more
efficient use fortunately madam
president
though some of our colleagues seem to
have forgotten that is exactly what we
did
only a week ago it's been less than five
days since president trump signed into
law another historic bipartisan rescue
package
targeted to americans who actually need
the help
we passed an entire second round of ppp
loans
to save small business jobs targeted to
the hardest hit
we renewed multiple kinds of additional
federal benefits for unemployed workers
including an
extra 300 supplement every week
there are billions for targeted food
assistance billions for targeted rental
assistance and many billions of dollars
for vaccine distribution
so we can finally beat this virus and
reopen the economy
in full these are the kinds of targeted
emergency programs that directly help
the most vulnerable
and we just poured almost another
trillion
dollars into them less than five
days ago along with more direct checks
that are
already arriving in households
accounts that madam president is what we
did
just five days ago this crisis has
not affected everyone equally the data
show that many upper
middle class americans have kept their
jobs
worked remotely and remained totally
financially
comfortable on the other hand some of
our fellow citizens have had their
entire existences turned upside down
and continue to suffer terribly we do
not need to let the speaker of the house
do socialism for rich people
in order to help those who need help our
duty
both to struggling americans and to
taxpayers is to focus on targeted relief
that will have the maximum impact and
help
the people who need it the most
that's what the experts say we should do
that's
where there is broad bipartisan support
and that's exactly what we did less than
one week ago when nearly 900 billion
dollars in more targeted relief
was signed into law for our people
madam president the democratic leader
now the senate today meets for a rare
new year's eve session
for one reason one reason only the
republican leader has a few
refused to allow us to vote on
legislation to provide the american
people
two thousand dollar checks he is twice
objected to my requests
to set a time for a vote on the measure
claiming yesterday that direct stimulus
checks were quote poorly targeted
bemoaning the idea that some of the
checks might go into
quote the hands of democrats rich
friends who don't need the help
unquote senator toomey said much the
same thing
well funny i don't remember the
republican leader and senator toomey
complaining about how a two trillion
dollar across the board
corporate tax cut was poorly targeted
because some large companies didn't need
the help nope
when corporations get a blanket tax
break that's fine by
the republican majority when the average
american gets a little help from their
government
it's poorly targeted i hope that every
american heard the objections by these
republican senators
i hope every american who has their
water or heat or electricity shut off
or had eviction notices stapled on top
of one another to their door
or had to choose which meal to skip on a
given day
i hope they all heard the reason they
will not receive two thousand dollar
checks
is because leader mcconnell thinks it
could wind up in the hands of quote
democrats rich friends now let's be very
clear
there is one way and only one way to
pass two thousand dollar checks before
the end of the year
and that's to pass the house bill it's
the only way to get the american people
the two thousand dollar checks they need
and deserve
the house is gone for the session any
modification
or addition to the house bill can't
become law
either the senate takes up and passes
the house bill
or struggling americans will not get two
thousand dollar checks during the worst
economic crisis
since the great depression and leader
mcconnell knows this
so he has said that the senate can only
vote on a bill that combines the checks
with other
unrelated partisan policies repeal
section 230
an investigation into the president's
dishonest and bogus claims of election
fraud
the republican leader claims that
president trump insists that all three
issues must be addressed in one bill
but of course the president has made no
such demand
president trump couldn't care less about
how the bills are packaged in congress
so the republican leader has invented an
excuse to prevent a clean up or down yes
or no vote on two thousand dollar checks
coming to the floor
this maneuver to combine all three
issues is intended to kill the
possibility of two thousand dollar
checks ever becoming
law just to prove it let me make this
offer to the republican majority
we're willing to vote on the other
issues that president trump mentioned
all the issues the republican leader
says must be addressed as so long as we
vote on them separately
that way two thousand dollar checks
could become law and we could debate all
the president's supposed concerns
we can vote on setting up a commission
to look at the president's roundly
rejected claims of voter fraud
would also have the commission look at
voter suppression and gerrymandering
that's completely unrelated to help
americans paying their bills
but we're willing to take a look at the
whole picture just give us a vote on the
house passed bill
so we can get help now to people who
desperately need it
heck we can also have a vote on
repealing 230 we can do it today
we'll use leader mcconnell's exact
language but he won't agree to that
because he knows his caucus
wouldn't actually support such an act
unlike the president
some members of this body understand
what 230 means
they understand that section 230 which
certainly needs change
actually enables the president to spew
his lies
we all know the 117th congress will have
to take a close look
at the relationship between liability
and reckless speech on the internet
but if leader mcconnell wants a vote on
these issues
we're here for it just give us a vote on
the house pass bill
and we can vote on whatever right-wing
conspiracy theory you'd like
we can even vote to set up a special
blue ribbon commission to determine
whether george's secretary of state
has a brother named ron if that would
make our republican friends happy
just don't let these conspiracy theories
and presidential fantasies get in the
way of helping actual people
people whose livelihoods have been torn
apart by this pandemic
peoples whose lives have been torn apart
by the administration's mismanagement of
this pandemic
people who need just a little direct
assistance
now the president's term thankfully will
end in twenty days
it's a term that's been marked by hate
and division
and turmoil he has so far used his term
to enrich himself in the wealthy
let's close out the term on a good note
for once he wants to help regular people
to give americans a leg up
let's allow them to do that we have a
chance at the end of this painful year
to give americans a reason to have some
hope in 2021.
the only thing standing in the way is
the republican senate majority
in a moment i will once again ask
consent that the senate set a time for a
vote on the house bill
to provide two thousand dollar checks to
the american people
remember democrats are willing to vote
on all the other issues the republicans
say the president supposedly cares about
just let us vote on a clean bill for the
2000 checks
so mr president madam president excuse
me
i ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed
to the immediate consideration of
calendar 645
hr 9051 a bill to increase the reca
recovery rebate amounts to two thousand
dollars for individuals
that the bill be read a third time in
the senate vote on passage
and then if passed the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table with no intervening
action or debate
is there objection object objection is
heard
senator from vermont
morning business is closed under the
previous order the senate will resume
consideration of the veto message on h.r
6395 which the clerk will report veto
message to accompany
h.r 6395 an act to authorize
appropriations for fiscal year 2021
for military activities of the
department of defense and so forth and
for other purposes
the senator from vermont thank you madam
president
let me briefly respond
to some of the points that majority
leader mcconnell
has made his inaccurate statements now i
am delighted
that after talking on the floor of the
senate for years about socialism
for the rich apparently that has gotten
across to my republican friends
of course that's what we do every single
day that's why we have
the level incredible level of ma of
income and wealth
inequality that exists in this country
because
decade after decade we have used
this body to provide massive tax breaks
to the rich
providing corporate welfare to
corporations who don't need it that is
socialism for the rich majority leader
is right
let's talk about in fact what is in this
bill
according to the tax policy center
less than one percent of the benefits of
the direct payments
that's the two thousand dollars for
working class adult that senator schumer
and i
are talking about less than one percent
would go to the top five percent of
americans
virtually nothing goes to the very very
rich
overwhelming majority of those funds
go to the middle class the working class
low-income people
who in the midst of this pandemic are in
desperate
economic condition now again i am
delighted to hear the majority leader
talking about
socialism for the rich and i hope we
will continue
that discussion in the next session so
let me talk about
the socialism for the rich that the
majority leader
is enthusiastically supportive of
majority leader helped lead this body to
pass trump's
tax bill now you want to talk about
socialism for the rich mr majority
leader
under that bill charles koch
one of the very richest people in
america
he has a net worth of 113 billion
dollars
that bill gave mr coke
a 1.4 billion dollar tax break
majority leader that sounds to me
like socialism for the rich
ah that's not all way in nevada we have
a gentleman named
sheldon adelson a major contributor to
the republican party
big funder for donald trump under that
same
tax bill led by the majority leader
sheldon adelson received a
560 million dollar
tax break guys worth 34 billion dollars
desperately needed that tax break 560
million dollars one or more tax breaks
for the rich want to talk about
socialism for the rich senator mcconnell
had no problem
giving a 104 million dollar tax refund
to amazon
over the past three years despite the
fact that that company made 30 billion
dollars in profit so
the argument that this bill in any
significant way benefits
the rich is just not accurate
but let us talk about who this bill
does benefit
this bill benefits tens of millions of
americans
who as a result of this pandemic have
lost their lives
lost their jobs sorry they have lost
their jobs
they have lost their incomes and some in
fact
have lost their lives these are people
who are going
hungry today we are seeing madam
president
a record-breaking level of hunger
in america today in the richest country
in the history of the world all over
this country and i receive emails from
people all over this country
people are frightened to death that they
are going to be evicted
from their homes and think about
what a four thousand dollar check or a
five thousand check
dollar check would mean to those
struggling families husband and wife
kids
and in fact let me give you an example
this is a problem taking place all over
this country
taking place in vermont taking place in
senator schumer state
it is taking place in kentucky in fact
in the state of kentucky a very
beautiful state i've had the pleasure of
being there a number of times
beautiful state but kentucky is
the state where 10 out of the 25
poorest counties in america exist
and i'm sure senator mcconnell is aware
that throughout his state
you've got thousands and tens of
thousands of people
living in economic desperation
and i'm talking about counties where 30
to 40 percent of people are living in
poverty
and where many thousands of residents
are trying to survive
on less than twenty thousand dollars a
year i'm talking about a state the state
of kentucky and i'm just
using kentucky as an example because
that's the state senator mcconnell
represents
true all over this country but in
kentucky
over 22 percent of the children are
living in poverty you think they might
need a little bit of help
more than in the state of kentucky more
than 190 000 workers
are making extremely low wages and where
over
half a million people earn less than
fifteen
dollars an hour somebody might want to
ask
those people what a two thousand 000
a check per adult would mean
and i'm talking in kentucky and i'll
never forget this because i visited
kentucky and talked to some of the
people there
kentucky has suffered a particular
opioid crisis
and i'll never forget talking to a
football coach who told me that a bunch
of the kids on his football team
were living with their grandparents are
on couches
because of the opioid epidemic in other
words the people in kentucky the people
of new york
the people in vermont are hurting they
need
help
so i say today
to senator mcconnell the leader here
let us address the horrendous economic
crisis
facing tens of millions of americans the
pandemic today is worse than it has ever
been
hopefully hopefully the vaccine will
make a profound difference but right now
people are hurting and they're looking
to this institution
they're looking to congress and the
house did the right thing they're now
looking to the senate they're looking
to senator mcconnell
and after all is said and done after all
of the legalese and i'm going to be
introducing some legalese at the moment
it comes down to one thing
senator mcconnell disagrees
with the proposal that senator schumer
and i are making
i got it that's fine it's a democracy as
the righteous point of view
i would love to have the debate on the
floor with senator mcconnell about
this legislation all that we are asking
is give us the opportunity to
vote up or down on whether or not
working families in this country
should be able to receive a two thousand
dollar check senator mcconnell disagrees
come to the floor tell us why you
disagree
and then we'll do what this institution
is supposed to do
we will have a vote
now the truth is that in the house
senator mcconnell knows
44 republicans voted
for the house bill which won by the way
by a two to one majority two-thirds
of the house voted to make sure that
working americans
will get a 2 000 check right here in the
senate
there are a number of republicans not
clear how many
who have already gone public and saying
they think
it is a good idea
that we go forward with the house bill
so all that i am asking senator
mcconnell
is give us a vote what is the problem
you could vote no
and by the way we need 60 votes a
majority no question to my mind
that a majority of the senators will
vote yes
but because of house rules we need 60
votes
so we're going to have to get 48
democrats that's what we got
plus 12 republicans can we get 12
republicans i don't know
maybe we can maybe we can't
but give us a vote what is the problem
what is the problem with having the
american people see how their senators
vote
on this issue of such enormous
importance
now as senator schumer indicated senator
mcconnell has some other concerns
concerned about section 230 of the
1996 uh federal telecommunications act
i'm sure that that is
absolutely on the minds of everybody in
vermont new york and kentucky
probably all that they're talking about
the 1996 telecommunications act but why
he wants to vote on that bring her to
the forum let's vote on it
as a separate bill we want to talk about
election
security senator schumer is right a lot
of issues out there
i'm concerned about voter suppression
i'm concerned about people waiting on
online five hours to cast the vote i'm
concerned about
voter intimidation senator mcconnell has
different points of view let's have that
discussion put together a commission
no problem bring that bill to the floor
but everybody understands that when you
combine all three elements
this is a poison pill designed to kill
that legislation
so after everything is said and done
all of this comes down to one simple
fact
will senator mcconnell the republican
leader of the u.s senate
allow this body to vote
on a bill which will provide two
thousand dollars
to per person to working class families
all across this country that's what this
whole debate is about
it's not whether you like the bill you
don't like we can have that debate
got three days left in this congress the
house did the right thing
it's now time for the senate to have
that vote
so madam president i ask unanimous
consent
that at 3 pm today thursday december
31st
the senate proceeds the consideration of
calendar number 645
hr 9051 to provide a two thousand dollar
direct payment
to the working class that the bill be
considered read a third time in the
senate vote
on passage of the bill and that if
passed the motion to reconsider be
considered
made and laid upon the table further
that following the vote on hr 9051
the senate resumed consideration of the
veto message on h.r 6395 the national
defense authorization act
and the senate vote on passage of the
bill the objections of the president to
the contrary
notwithstanding all with no intervening
action
or debate is there objection object
objection is heard thank you madam
president
the clerk will call the rule mr
alexander
madam president the assistant democratic
leader i ask consent the quorum call be
suspended without objection madam
president
i'd like to for a moment just reflect on
where we are
at this session of the united states
senate and
the choices that have been made i want
to thank senator sanders
senator schumer for bringing this with
clarity to the floor of the senate
we support two thousand dollars as a
helping hand to people across the united
states
there's a limitation on the amount that
individuals receive
if they make more than seventy five
thousand dollars or if their family
makes more than a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
but we are following the template that
has been
employed both with the cares act
and with our own covent relief act of
just a few days ago
we've been told by the department of the
treasury that if you want to put money
into the hands of
americans that desperately need it this
is the best way to do it the quickest
way to do it there are better ways i'm
sure
but in time of crisis we need to respond
and respond in a timely way
and so senator sanders and senator
schumer have brought
to the floor for consideration we we
hope
a bill that has already passed the house
of representatives the
significance of this is that the house
is now in recess
and not scheduled to return in this
congressional session
so whatever happens over here cannot be
a new bill
there's no house to send it to and no
time to pass it
but rather has to be an up or down vote
on a bill that has passed the house
as is and that's what they've come to
the floor now for three straight days
asking
senator schumer has asked repeatedly to
senator
mcconnell the republican leader a simple
request
whether you're for the house bill or
against the house bill
allow the senate to be the senate allow
us to vote on the bill
for those of us who support it to vote
on it and it isn't a lock it isn't a
guarantee that we're going to win
and prevail with that vote 48 democratic
senators and you need 60
votes we need help from the other side
four or five republican senators say
they support it as well but we don't
know if we have the 12
if all of our members can be here in
this
era of covet 19 sadly even some of our
senators have
illnesses in the family which may make
it impossible for them to be here
so there's no guarantee we win but there
will be a guarantee
that we are recorded and our positions
are known to the voters across america
that is a simple request and yet time
and time
and time again the republican leader
senator mcconnell has said no
i'm worried over what's happening to
this institution
not just with this instance but with
what we've seen over the past several
years
we will conclude this calendar year
having voted on the floor of this united
states senate
29 times on amendments 29 in the course
of a year
in what is supposedly the world's
greatest deliberative body
i guess i shouldn't complain it's a 30
increase over last year
when we voted on 22 amendments in the
entire calendar year the senate is
out of business and out to lunch when it
comes to legislating
and that's a fact and all we're asking
for
is the chance to legislate a two
thousand dollar helping hand
to families across america i've heard
over and over again
that we're just trying to featherbed the
rich we're trying to give
big checks to rich people well senator
sanders made a point of that earlier
less than one percent of the money that
we're asking for is going to go to the
top five percent
when it came time for tax policy and tax
breaks
many of the people complaining the
loudest about two thousand dollars were
giving away
millions of dollars to the richest
people in america without
any hesitation well today's another day
and today's a different america today we
are facing a country
that is in the depths of the crisis
created by covet 19.
the numbers coming back to us every
night on the news are heartbreaking
numbers
i i understand and most of us do those
wonderful women and men who are
in the health care business usually are
very stoic and calm in reporting
the reality of their lives not so
anymore
more and more doctors and nurses are
breaking down on television as they
describe the scenes in emergency rooms
across this country they describe
the reality of telling families that
they cannot be by the bedside
of one of their loved ones who's about
to die and they break down in tears
and tell us they don't know how much
more of this they can take
that is the reality of america it is not
an america of people vastly rich
sitting by the swimming pool hoping
congress sends them more money
it's an america of those patients and
their families
and the people who are out of work and
the businessmen and women who've lost
everything who need a hand from this
government
if there is one thing about america i
hope it's clear no matter what your
political persuasion
we are caring people if there is a
hurricane that hits florida
i care about it if there's a tornado
that hits the state of nebraska i care
about it
and we come together on a bipartisan
basis to help those families
now more than ever those families need
us to do something significant in their
lives
how can you see the scenes on television
every night
of the parade of cars lined up in texas
in kentucky in illinois hoping
they can get some food to give to their
families
are those grifters and chiselers who are
just trying to get a free meal
i don't think so would you sit in your
car for an hour or two
for food unless you really needed it
i think those people really need it and
many of them are heartbroken that
they're in this situation
some are even embarrassed and they
shouldn't be that they have been the
victims of this economy so all we're
asking senator mcconnell is give us a
chance to vote you can vote no if you
wish
give us a chance to vote for the two
thousand dollars that can make a
difference in a person's life
four thousand dollars for a husband and
wife who are struggling to get by
rent checks mortgage payments
car payments utility bills
things that really are basic to families
survival
we're trying to help and i think we
should be given that chance
we have tried time and again we have the
support of president trump in this
effort and i'm glad
to have it i think we have enough
support in this chamber
to come up with 60 votes i pray that we
will if we're given that chance
and i hope that the senate republican
leader is not afraid of that outcome
he shouldn't be he has two of his
incumbent republican senators in a
runoff election who both publicly said
they want to vote for this and yet he
stops them
he's the one who's put an end to their
opportunity
why shouldn't he give them the
opportunity to vote yes
he even refuses in this situation with
this looming election
to bring this matter to the floor for an
honest up or down
bipartisan vote i listened to the
stories that were told by
senator sanders and others about the
plight of people in this country
and how much they count on us
and frankly how many of them have given
up on us they just don't believe
the congress of the united states is in
touch with the reality of america
if we are in touch with the reality in
our home states
in our home towns we should do something
something significant to end this new
year on the right
note i plead with the republican leader
who has the power the one the sole
member of congress of 100 members
he has the power to bring this matter to
a vote and to do it immediately within
the hour
we could call the members who've
returned to washington yesterday
together
take a vote soon in a matter of minutes
and know once and for all whether we
have 60 votes that are necessary to pass
this measure
and then we can pass the override of the
president's veto of the defense
authorization bill a critical piece of
legislation
that will be the right way to end this
year let us not
end it in suspense as to whether or not
we're going to come to the aid and
assistance of american families
who rely on us time and again to be
there
when america needs a helping hand let's
do our job
let's fill this chamber with senators
who actually vote on an issue that makes
a difference
in the lives of americans that's what we
were elected to do
we have no excuse if we fail i yield the
floor and suggest the absence of corps
clerk will call the rule mr alexander
so
so
so
mr president the senator from
connecticut
thank you mr president we are here in
the waning hour
senator we are we are in a quorum call i
ask that the
quorum call be lifted without objection
uh we are here mr president in the
waning hours
of 2020
expectant and hopeful about the coming
year
and i want to wish all of my colleagues
a very healthy
and happy new year in the hope that
we will fulfill the promise of
our constituents our country our
constitution
in moving forward to meet and conquer
the pandemic that still ravages our
nation
and renew our economy
that still
is failing
we are the greatest nation in the
history of the world
and americans are hurting
this body has taken positive and
important steps
toward meeting this public health and
economic crisis
as well as the
hurt and harm that continue to plague
americans
in a number of important relief packages
we have helped to meet those needs and
enable the nation to bridge the gap
created by this pandemic an economic
gap that has become
a chasm a
cliff that seems without end
and for many of our fellow citizens
a time of unparalleled and
unanticipated
pain the
relief package that we've passed most
recently
i think we can be proud to say is the
second largest in our nation's history
and it will provide
a second round of paycheck protection
loans forgivable becoming grants
so that small businesses can keep their
doors open
more aid for our transportation
and education system money to distribute
the vaccine that will be a lifesaver so
for so many americans
and other important
aid including
a six hundred dollar stimulus payment
for every american who
is making less than seventy five
thousand dollars that's
real assistance for a family of four
twenty four hundred dollars
because every child as well as adult
receives that money but all of that 906
billion dollars is only a down payment
it is a life raft
and it has to be followed by an even
more robust
bigger bolder package
to provide real relief and sustenance
for the survival of our economy
and literally the survival of americans
who are
struggling to put food on the table and
to buy medicine
pay rent and mortgages clothe their
children
we have all told our stories on the
floor of the senate during 2020 about
constituents waiting in food line
hurting for the funds needed to stay in
their
homes or apartment
and to pay for the medicine that is
literally a matter of
life and death
we've told those stories we've talked
about americans who are struggling
we have the opportunity now to do
something about it
and so i appeal to my republican
colleagues
very bluntly and simply
give us a vote on the cash act let us
vote
on a stand-alone twelve hundred
two thousand dollar stimulus payment
bill
allow every one of us to go on record
on that two thousand dollar stimulus
payment bill that would add fourteen
hundred dollars
to the six hundred dollars already
provided not to minimize the importance
of the six hundred dollars
but it is inadequate
it is insufficient it is unacceptable
because it fails to provide
the basic need to
meet the desperate and dire straits of
so many
americans
we're talking about families
that need that money to buy bread and
milk
paper towels and toilet paper
goods and services that are necessary to
the survival
of their families
six hundred dollars is simply not
enough and that is why
i call on my fellow
group colleagues
to persuade their leader
that we should be permitted this vote
because i believe that if there's a vote
it will pass having spoken to
republican colleagues here i have no
doubt
none that that standalone
two thousand dollar stimulus payment
measure cash act would pass
overwhelmingly
just as did the six 600
payment as part of a larger bill
and the simple fact is
that measure is the only viable vehicle
any other measure loaded with
other provisions whether it's the
section 230 reform or a commission to
investigate the last election
on fictitious fraud is
doomed it is doomed logistically
it is doomed legally and physically
there is no way for the house
to pass it only the house bill
if passed can provide americans
with the two thousand dollar stimulus
payment that they
so desperately need
only the house bill provides that relief
any other measure will
be doomed because the house cannot
come back to pass it in the time that we
have left
in this session and so
the majority leader is essentially
blocking a step that will literally save
lives
supported by the vast majority of the
american people
a significant part of his own conference
and every democrat
and have no doubt every democrat will
vote for it we've clamored for it
a higher stimulus payment for months
when the majority leader
refused to come to the table and then
when the president of the united states
failed to lift a finger he was on the
golf course
when it might have made a difference in
raising that 600 amount
dollar amount higher during the
negotiation
but looking forward there's a way to
provide this relief to americans without
leaving here in
a contest of blame
but in a new year of
mutual congratulations
pass the two thousand dollar stimulus
payment plan as a stand-alone clean bill
now i just want to say
i'm probably the only senator
who has supported two
measures one of them actually passed by
the congress and signed by the president
to reform section 230
and the other unanimously voted out of
the judiciary committee they
reform section 230 and i support
reforming section 230. i have
hardly been uncritical of section 230
and there should be major reform
of section 230 but it has to be done in
a careful
deliberate and considered way as a
separate measure not as a meat ax
in a totally unrelated bill
the two thousand dollar payment bill
that provides real relief to americans
loading the cash act with poison pills
is obstruction it is not
constructive legislating and it fails
to meet the test
of this moment
it is vital that we move forward
to provide struggling americans with
this relief
and scuttling
the two thousand dollar stimulus payment
bill
with a half bait meat act
evisceration of section 230 is
cruel and downright
stupid it betrays
the mission and obligation that we have
in these waning days of 2020.
americans need more help
and they need hope
help and hope are
embodied in the vaccine
unfortunately the rollout of this
vaccine despite the eight billion
dollars contained in
the latest pandemic relief bill has been
hopelessly
behind schedule the number of doses
distributed
is roughly a tenth of what it should be
even under the scaled back schedule
that this administration has adopted 20
million
vaccinations were promised by the end of
the year
that number was way below the initial
promise
and only a tenth of them probably about
two million will be actually provided
instead of taking responsibility
or taking control president trump
is still tweeting
instead of action more talk
only action will save lives
and either he doesn't care enough
or he doesn't really see what is
necessary to do
in order to save these lives
because the distribution of this vaccine
is a matter of life and death
and so using the defense production act
mobilizing america making sure states
have the resources they need providing
money
to hospitals and making sure there are
the vials syringes training for workers
as well as the facilities to transport
store
and distribute this vaccine are
essential now
they are missing at this moment and
the president is where the buck stops
now i look forward to a 2021 when a new
president
will expand the stimulus payments to
individuals
and when many of the other gaps left
unfinished
action that still is necessary will be
fulfilled by another
more robust bigger bolder
pandemic relief program i hope we'll
have the same bipartisan support that we
saw
at the end of this year for the latest
i hope we will overcome
the divisions that have prevented us
from doing what is really necessary
and adding 1400 to the 600
already provided we need to do more for
small businesses
yes there will be another round of ppp
payments but this chasm faced by
restaurants
retailers small businesses
struggling to keep their doors open keep
their people on
payroll during the holiday we've seen
them all
and talked to them their stories are
riveting
and heartbreaking business people who
have poured their souls
and hearts and lives into these
businesses only to see them
threatened with extension
and this crisis has a racial justice
aspect that cannot be ignored
because disproportionately
the businesses that have failed are
black and brown owned
disproportionately the lives
lost have been in
black and brown communities
disproportionately
the jobs lost
have been in those same communities
black and brown communities that have
suffered more than any other
as a result of this pandemic and so we
need to make sure that they receive
the vaccines as well as therapeutics
and testing that is necessary to save
lives
we are in the midst of a racial justice
movement
it affects policing and criminal justice
but it also affects our schools where
the zip code
of a child's residence can mean the
difference between
quality education or not
where black and brown communities
suffer twice or three times the death
rate
of others as a result of this pandemic
where job discrimination
still exists and in housing redlining
still afflicts these communities
and where environmental quality
rivers lakes air still
can be disproportionately contaminated
and polluted
in communities inhabited by black and
brown
people we are
here in the last day of an unprecedented
and catastrophic year
more than 342 000 of our fellow
americans
are dead as a result of this insidious
virus over 342 000
gifts unwrapped
places at tables
left open and
many of them without final goodbyes
this past year will go down as one of
the hardest in our history
i think we all hope for a better year
but it will come only if
we take the kind of action that
apparently
my republican colleagues are failing to
provide
today which is to meet the needs
to match the moment of
these desperate and dire straits
of so many america the failure to
approve an
additional fourteen hundred dollars
and pass the cash act
is a haunting omission
and my hope is that
the hopes of a hurting nation will be
met
in this new year that the calls for
justice and relief
will be heard and that
the ailing and sick
not just physically but
emotionally will be met this crisis has
been
one of physical health care
but also mental health care and the
emotional strains can be seen in the
rising rates
of domestic violence
substance abuse disorder and addiction
and so many other areas
where mental and emotional stress and
anxiety
have taken a toll
the hopes of a fearful
and grieving nation rest
on our shoulders and we cannot let them
down
thank you mr president i yield the floor
mr president senator from utah mr
president i stand today
to honor my friend gary herbert governor
of the state of utah
for the last 12 years who after a long
career
in public service is now embarking
on a really well-deserved hard-earned
retirement
he's served in the state of utah
and done so with great enthusiasm and
dedication
and spirit and i'm grateful to have
worked alongside him
throughout his tenure serving our great
state
gary herbert was born in american fork
utah and grew up in orem
he served a two-year mission for the
church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints
on the east coast and later attended
brigham young university my alma mater
he first began his public service in
college
serving in the utah army national guard
for six years and eventually becoming a
staff sergeant
after his time in the national guard he
set up a real estate firm
and was very successful eventually
becoming the president
of the utah association of realtors
also served as president of the utah
association of counties by the way
starting in 1990 he served as a
commissioner on the utah county
commission
he served there for 14 years and it was
at that point that he began
his statewide service within utah you
see in 2004
when john huntsman ran for the
governor's seat gary became
his running mate running alongside
huntsman as his lieutenant governor
with the pair going on to win the race
in november
it was then that i first got to know
gary herbert
personally when i was hired to be
governor huntsman's general counsel
one of my first memories of gary herbert
uh
which to me seems like it was just day
before yesterday
occurred when we all began moving into
the governor's office suite
just the day before herbert and huntsman
were sworn into office
gary came in and provided us all with a
warm welcome but he didn't stop at the
welcome
he offered really sound and heartfelt
advice
about the importance of staying grounded
as we were entering the political fray
he explained that long after our service
in the huntsman herbert administration
had expired we want to be able to look
back
and be pleased about the relationships
that we had formed with each other but
especially the relationships that
we had maintained with our families
our children and god
i soon learned that governor herbert
in addition to being wise and in
addition to being a skilled
and valuable statesman was
also a formidable athlete right after he
and governor huntsman
were sworn in the staff got together as
a team several times in the governor's
mansion
where we soon discovered there was a
ping pong table in the basement
i then learned the hard way that
governor herbert's
athletic skills including his ping pong
skills
or off the charts well serving governor
huntsman i always found gary to be
friendly approachable and always willing
to tackle
every single assignment with eagerness
and poise whenever governor huntsman's
schedule became chaotic
or would change unexpectedly as happens
in any governor's office or any
senator's office
for that matter particularly at certain
times of year
lieutenant governor herbert would
routinely be dispatched to speak
on huntsman's behalf often sending him
to remote corners of the state
and often at really inconvenient times
he never once complained and he was not
only willing but he was always
eager and and happy he felt fortunate
for the opportunity to help that's the
kind of enthusiasm that the people
of the state of utah have benefited from
for so long as a result of gary
herbert's service
you see he's never lost that not during
his entire time as lieutenant governor
not during his entire time as governor
you can tell that he is exactly where he
wants to be and that he feels privileged
and even blessed to be able to serve the
people of utah
likewise whenever there was an issue
that needed to be addressed by the
governor
even within the office or on the capital
compound
but where the governor was unable to
meet with
the particular group in question gary
was always assigned to the case
he would meet with as he described it
all the different stakeholders
he'd get together the legislators county
commissioners
the citizens from this or that part of
the state lobbyists lawyers who may have
been involved
in addition to other members of governor
huntsman's
administration he'd bring them all in
together
and he'd wade through all the intricate
and often pedestrian
details of the matter you see he he
wanted to get to the bottom
of the issue he wanted to understand it
what's more he had the skill of figuring
out the best
path forward for all parties involved
and for making everyone feel heard
and understood if ever whenever there
was
a way to achieve a win-win gary found it
and he brought people to it and they
were always grateful as a result
the same traits that i saw in him as
lieutenant governor
would go on to make him an effective and
beloved governor himself
in office now as governor since 2009
gary herbert is currently the nation's
longest-serving governor
and our state has seen exciting
achievement
and tremendous prosperity with governor
herbert at the helm
in the last eight years utah has seen
continued
steady growth in our economy
with improvement in our gdp
number of jobs and unemployment rate
we've seen the boom of silicon slopes
we celebrated the centennial uh assessed
centennial
of the driving of the golden spike
when it was an honor to stand alongside
governor and mrs herbert at that
celebratory reenactment
on that particular occasion governor
herbert and his wife jeanette
showed their characteristic enthusiasm
by uh arriving
in their finest 1869 apparel
just to re-commemorate the moment and it
made all the difference it made it all
feel much more authentic
and so too was it an honor to join gary
when president trump came to utah
to announce his decision to shrink the
bears ears national monument
when we could all stand together and
celebrate the fact that
someone in washington had heard our
concerns within the state
and saw fit to redraw the boundaries in
a manner
more compatible with local interests and
concerns
through his enthusiasm and his zeal gary
herbert
has championed our state and the things
that we stand for he's done so
very consistently very enthusiastically
he can
rattle off figures and metrics about
utah at the drop of a hat i'm convinced
the man can do it in his sleep and do so
infectiously and persuasively and he's a
compelling
spokesman for our state's values his
spirit
has helped utah to attract talent and
investment not only from
throughout the united states but uh from
throughout the world
and to make it the good place that it is
to live not only that but
gary has been an instrumental partner in
supporting initiatives that
reflect and strengthen the values of our
state
to champion the reclamation of our lands
he signed into law the utah transfer of
public lands act
he also signed into law innovative
criminal justice reforms
in utah he was at the cutting edge of
that movement
making a far-reaching impact across our
state
and that ended up having impacts
elsewhere
in fact his work in utah and criminal
justice reform
helped pave the way for the work that
congress and president trump
were able to achieve at the federal
level through the passage of the first
step act
he's been a strong supporter of utah's
family culture
and was helpful in the senate's work
promoting the child tax credit
during our tax reform discussions just
three years ago
and on a more personal note gary herbert
also had the wisdom
to put my brother tom on the utah
supreme court
in so doing he's been a champion for
textualism the notion that judges are
there
to interpret the law based on what the
law says rather than on the basis
of what it might have said for all of
his public achievements
gary is perhaps most proud and
always most conscious of and most aware
of and most concerned about his own role
as a husband as a father and as a
grandfather
gary and his wife jeanette have six
children together as well as 16
grandchildren and he's known to
encourage them to follow
in his footsteps and marry up
in myriad ways governor herbert has been
a champion
and a spokesman for all that is good
about our state it's been an honor to
serve
the people of utah with him
and i wish governor herbert and his wife
jeanette
all the best as they embark
on the next chapter of their lives
together
thank you mr president you have the
floor
so
so
majority leader as if an executive
session
i ask unanimous consent that we're
suspected of saskan nomination the
motion to reconsider
be considered made and laid upon the
table and the president be immediately
notified of the sentence action
without objection i adams consent the
senate being a period of morning
business
the senators should be permitted to
speak
for up to 10 minutes each without
objection
as united's consent the senate proceed
to the immediate consideration of h.r 40
44
which was received from the house the
clerk will report
h.r 4044 an act to amend the federal
water pollution control act
to reauthorize the national estuary
program and for other purposes
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure i ask unanimous
consent the bill be considered
a third time without objection i know no
further debate on the bill
if there's no further debate the
question is on passage of the bill
all in favor say aye aye all opposed no
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the bill is passed ask unanimous consent
the motion to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table
without objection as united's consent
the committee on
energy and natural resources be
discharged from further consideration of
h.r
1472 and the senate proceed to its
immediate consideration
the clerk report h.r 1472 an act to
rename the homestead national monument
of america
near beatrice nebraska as the homestead
national historical park
with abjection the committee is
discharged an incident will proceed to
the measure
ashton adamson sent the bill be
considered a third time in past and the
motion to reconsider be considered made
and later from the table
without objection now mr president i ask
united's consent that when the senate
completes its business today
it adjourn until 12 noon friday january
1st further that fall in the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal of proceedings be
approved to date
morning business will be closed and the
time for the two leaders be reserved for
their use later in the day
finally following leader remarks the
senate resume consideration of the veto
message on h.r
6395 without objection
so there's no further business come
before the senate i stand adjourned
under the previous order
the sin stands confirm adjourn until 12
noon tomorrow
you